-Guys, it is important
to remember there are
two sides to every news story.
To make sure you get to see
important issues from all sides,
we have invited
two of our writers
who have very different
points of view.
We will examine their opinions
in a segment we call
"Point, Counterpoint."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Ally, Amber,
thanks for being here today.
First topic.
President Trump
temporarily ended
the longest government shutdown
in U.S. history on Friday
without even getting his wall.
Is it worth shutting it down in
two weeks for him to try again?
Ally?
-Absolutely not.
It will throw this country
into turmoil.
How is it not illegal for him
to use the livelihood of all
these Americans as leverage
for him to get a stupid monument
to himself?
-A monument to himself.
Amber?
-If I had a monument of myself,
it would be so cool!
It would be just like
the Lincoln Memorial,
except I'd be sitting like this.
[ Laughter ]
As the plaque would say
"She sure did like margaritas."
-Another great point.
Next topic.
BuzzFeed reported
President Trump directed
his lawyer, Michael Cohen,
to commit perjury,
and although
Robert Mueller's team
said that wasn't quite accurate,
they didn't refute it, either.
Too early to throw around
the word "impeachment"? Ally?
-No, because this is literally
one of the reasons
Nixon was impeached.
And we all know Trump did it.
The only thing I worry about
is that right now
our alternative
is human robot Mike Pence.
-Human robot. Amber?
-[ Robotic voice ]
I am a human robot.
I know how to walk, how to talk.
But no one ever taught me
how to love.
[ Normal voice ] Hey, remember
how data from "Star Trek"
was always like,
"I wish I was real"?
And I would always be like,
"How do you have
all these strong feelings
when you're a robot?
Something doesn't add up."
-Seth, what she's saying
is completely off topic.
-Ally, it's called
"Point, Counterpoint."
She makes a point,
you make a counterpoint.
-We're all doing a good job!
-Next topic.
The field of Democrats
running for President in 2020
grows by the day,
but this could also mean
another vicious battle
to become the nominee.
Can the Democrats survive their
own primary season? Ally?
-Honestly, who knows?
People already have their
claws out on social media.
I just don't get
why these people
want to destroy their own party.
-Destroy their own party.
Amber?
-♪♪ It's my party,
I'll destroy it if I want to ♪♪
♪♪ Destroy it if I want to,
destroy it if I want to ♪♪
-Those aren't the words!
-♪♪ And you would do it, too ♪♪
♪♪ Flappy flippy dee floo ♪♪
♪♪ Ba ba beep boop bop,
ah ba ba ba ba ba ♪♪
-Next topic, please!
-Finally, the Chinese government
has arrested a scientist
they say gene-edited two babies.
Should be this illegal,
or could it help parents
protect their future children
from disease? Ally.
-Helpful or not, once
governments gets their hands
on this technology,
it will be bad news.
As it is, I refuse to
give my DNA to 23andMe
because they're just
going to sell it.
We need a president who will
pass legislation on this soon.
-Maybe I'll run for president.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
You know, if you were serious
about being president,
you'd announce it formally.
-All right.
-Where's she going?
-I don't know.
♪♪♪♪
-Good evening from New York.
Our top story tonight is about
migrating tree frogs that --
Can I help you?
-Hi. I'm Amber Ruffin.
And I'm running for
President of the United States!
-Uh...great.
What's your platform?
-Margaritas for everyone!
-I don't hate it.
-Okay, bye! Love you!
-Love you, too?
♪♪♪♪
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-I can't believe you did it.
-I can't believe
you didn't do it on this show.
-Oh. Is that something
other people are doing?
-No.
But it'd be cool if they did.
-Okay, then.
I'm running for President!
-Oh, shut up, Ally.
-Fair.
-This has been
"Point, Counterpoint."